[موسيقى]
جدي كان مسؤول عن المهبل القديم 23 24 25
وكان هو تحت ايده عشر افراد بيشتغلوا في
كسوه الشريفه وتعاقبه الحكايه ديت ويكفي
ان احنا نقول لك لنا الشرف ان القسم تخرج
من تحت ايدينا تلات سنين او اربع سنين
واربعه دي كمان
[موسيقى]
خدتها من والدي وبحاول دلوقتي ان انا
انقلها كمان لاولادي وزي ما اتعلمها والدي
من جدي بحاول يعمل نقلتها بحسافرها الحمد
لله رب العالمين وادينا بنكمل المشوار لحد
وقتنا هذا
[موسيقى]
الاول بنثبته بالخيط بعد كده بنحط الحشو
فوق الكرتون وبنشتغل عليه برضو بالخيط
بحيث ان احنا يعني نثبته تثبيت كويس
اخر حاجه بقى مرحله اللي هي مرحله السلك
او مرحله القصب يعني في بدل ممكن برضو بدل
السلك بيبقى فيه مثلا قصب زي الحاجات اللي
معي كده او اللي ورايا
عشان خاطر برضو ما يبقاش التقنيفه برضو
جامده على العميل
وطبعا هي عمليه موريكه لحكايه السلك كمان
حكايه قوي انك تشتغل بسلك نحاس وايدك صعبه
شويه